but we begin with life-threatening
danger in the western half of the u.s
massive wildfires fueled by hot and dry
conditions these pitchers are from just
outside dallas texas where an entire
block an entire block was burned by
raging grass fire and in california
where crews are desperately working to
contain the oak fire the state's largest
wildfire of the year
jonathan bigliotti is in mariposa county
near yosemite national park jonathan
good morning
and good morning to you nate we came to
this remote ridge line to show you where
this fire is burning deep inside this
canyon fire crews made significant
progress battling these flames overnight
stopping the spread it only spread by
about 600 acres remarkable when you
consider over this weekend it exploded
to 16 thousand acres
at least 17 thousand acres have been
scorched across central california
where the oak fire has many communities
facing potential devastation this is not
normal thousands of residents are under
evacuation orders as the fire leaves a
trail of destruction devouring at least
55 structures while at least 3 200 homes
remain under threat the fire was coming
quickly it was now or never we had to go
nearly 3 000 firefighters from all over
the state were brought into the steep
terrain to battle the flames that
scientists linked to climate change you
have really hot weather 100 plus
temperatures you have a lot of unburned
fuel that was mainly attributed to the
beetle kill in the last few years and
extreme drought conditions similar dry
conditions are causing havoc nationwide
in alaska more than 530 wildfires have
burned an area the size of connecticut
in texas dramatic images of a
neighborhood engulfed in flames show
just how quickly a wildfire can spread
at least 15 homes in this dallas suburb
of bulge springs were destroyed
yesterday after a rotary cutter started
a brush fire it's just stuff but it's
still amazing to see what survives
back here in california steve and andrea
ward came back to see their home after
watching it burst into flames live on
local news it's just amazing that that
trunk is still right there too i mean
it's just
this is amazing
there has been a lot of devastation at
this hour the good news the fire is now
16 percent contained and fire officials
now say they hope to get full
containment by this weekend
vlad
all right jonathan thank you very much